[Music]
foreign
this is talk TV
[Music]
I'm Piers Morgan an assistant tonight a
sporting outrage becomes an
international Scandal Australia's
cricketers didn't break the rules what's
the point of winning without Integrity
as Putin's bombs pounded Ukraine is top
man in London hosted a lavish party with
blues and vodka to cheer on the illegal
Invasion what the hell was a lord
represented the Britain the British
conservative party doing there I'll ask
him he joins me live
uh plus we're joined by a well-known
movie star and comedian who's now turned
the spotlight on free speech on the
vicious regime initiative Iran he'll
join me live in the studio
[Music]
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored good
evening welcome to Petersburg downstairs
so first of all a an apology for the
state of me uh I have a summer head cold
as rare but vicious little things which
has reduced my voice to Barry White's
secret brother uh so my apologies for
that we'll have to just get through this
together now you don't need to be a
cricket fan or even a sports fan to be
incensed by bad sportsmanship every so
often there's a sporting related abusive
basic Fair Play That's So outrageous it
transcends the game to become a national
or even Global Ferrari the Bedlam that
broke out during the ashes test match at
laws yesterday it most definitely met
that Mark on and off the pitch the home
of cricket witnessed an act of
unsporting treachery by Australia which
got the entire nation raging let's have
a look at it
that's another short ball
oh now this is going to be interesting
[Applause]
well be out a double blow for Australia
out for 10.
well England's Johnny bairstow last week
held a hero over dispatching just stop
oil protesters ducks a ball and then
scratches his mark inside the crease
something that suggests that he was
in the Apparently mistaken belief the
over was finished that's what batsman do
when an over is finished the umpires
were preparing to move on for the next
over sebasto wanders up the Wicket to
speak to his batting partner England's
Captain Ben Stokes again this is what
most bats will do at the end of an over
the Australian Wiki keeper Alex Carey
threw the ball at the stumps anyway and
basto was subsequently given out
according to the laws of the cricket let
me be clear that was the correct
decision
the law says that is out Australia
didn't cheat well not like they cheated
a few years ago when they were caught
using sandpaper to manipulate the ball
that was cheating but what they did at
Lords yesterday wasn't in the spirit of
the game they knew we all knew the best
wasn't seeking to gain any advantage he
genuinely thought the ball was dead the
over was finished this was the
equivalent of a footballer tapping the
ball into an empty net when everyone
else on the pitch leaves the game has
stopped and the reaction from the crowd
well it was unprecedented
[Applause]
[Music]
now I've been going to Lord since I was
a teenager I've never seen or heard
anything like that not in the hallowed
confines of the Pavilion set the scene a
bit here laws is a place which embodies
the genteel qualities of cricket think
of a braying English football crowd
foaming with impassion Fury every
perceived slight and then imagine the
exact opposite that's well that's the
Lord's Pavilion in particular
well-heeled members pay thousands for
spot in the long run often waiting 20 or
30 years for the chance to become
members that room dates back to the 19th
century this kind of raucous abusive
reaction I have to say was unacceptable
but is also unprecedented and then a
measure of the pain that has caused
Britain's biggest newspaper cleared his
front page for the story branding it out
of order they quoted one outrage Cricket
fan who said Australia that is pathetic
actually possibly want to win an Ash's
test match like that that fan was me
well Ben Stokes agreed with me and said
the same thing and Britain's prime
minister Rishi sunak agreed with both of
us his official spokesman said he simply
wouldn't want to win a game in the
manner Australia did and asked whether
Mr sunak thought that Australia's
actions were not in keeping with the
spirit of Cricket the spokesman ad is
simply yes and that's the point
there are the rules of the game which
Australia clearly followed and then
there's the spirit of the game which in
my opinion Australia ran over with a
bulldozer it's hard to Define exactly
what constitutes the spirit of the game
but most sports fans you kind of know it
when we see it being abused it's why
Diego Maradona genius though he was will
always be thought of as a cheat banging
the football fans for his hand of God
goal against us in the world cup and why
paralodic Cameo will always be revered
by contrast when he did this while
playing for West Ham
[Applause]
goalkeeper was lying down injured
decanio could have done what many
players would have done and just scored
the goal he hadn't injured the
goalkeeper but he did the right thing
the sporting thing and as a result he'll
all would be remembered as a magnificent
Sportsman
and let's come to a man named Trevor
Chapel who will always be reviled for
once bowling underarm to stop Australia
losing a match against New Zealand
they haven't believed it
and that's a disappointing finish
disappointed growing affecting the crowd
boom
it's all over
so what happened there was that New
Zealand wanted six to win off the last
ball in a one-day game against Australia
so Australia's Captain Trevor Chapel's
brother Greg instructed him to bowl
underarm to just prevent
any chance of New Zealand winning that
too was in the rules at the time they
got changed later after that incident
but it clearly wasn't in the spirit of
the game
England Stuart broad summed up the best
o debacle perfectly
you'll ever be remembered for it yeah he
said yes
I suspect that's true Alex Carey the
wiki keeper will probably now always
have an asterisk by his name as the guy
that did that to Johnny bairstow as will
his captain who didn't withdraw the
appeal and although some Australian
media reveled in what happened others
were more embarrassed the Australian
Delhi Telegraph said Australia forever
taints famous ashes win and the sports
journalist Phil Rothfield wrote the
greatest moments in Australian sport are
often not about winning but great acts
of sportsmanship
this Ash's win will be remembered but
not for the right reasons well exactly
where's the glory in winning a sport if
in the process of winning you abandon
basic honor integrity and fair play
well joining me is former England
cricket Legends Jeffrey boycott the
conservative peer Lord Marlin who was at
Lords yesterday and the Australian
cricket commentator Melinda Farrell I'm
also joined in the studio by the
associates of the Daily Mirror Kevin
McGuire okay well this is a a great
lineup to have so Jeffrey I read your
brilliant column in the telegraph Daily
Telegraph earlier today in which you
demanded an apology from the Australian
team tell me why you think that is in
order
well I didn't demand anything I said it
would be waste look if he doesn't know
the rights between playing
right to the letter of the law
and what is good for the spirit of the
game then I don't know I can't teach him
um in 1932-33 when the body line was
play it was Australia that first started
it by sending a telegram that didn't
like Bodyline which was within the rules
by Jardine and his team beating them and
they sent the telegram to the MCC saying
this is not Cricket it's not in the
spirit of the game so those in Australia
that were siding with the Australians so
play into the letter of the the Lord as
it were should they go back to
1932-33 and also their Captain told Plum
Warner who was the manager of the MCC
team and went into the dressing room and
one and Warner got told by the captain
of Australia there are two teams out
there and only one is playing Cricket so
they didn't like the way it was being
played within the rules and they went
further than that
the after this series was lost by
Australia they got England pressured
them to change the rules of the game the
laws of the game and they also said when
we're due to come to you in 1938 to play
a tour of England if you're going to
bold body line we're not coming and MCC
said okay we won't and they came on the
tour so they were the first to start
this about the standards in the game and
if Pat Cummins and his team don't know
what standards are then I can't teach
him and if you want to win at any cost
that's not good and Jeffrey and Jeffrey
is known for gamesmanship underhand
things Jeffrey for those who are not
massive Cricket fans but are aware of
this because all over the front pages
and the TV news in your estimation what
happened here that was wrong
well first of all Johnny bestow was
dogzy Daft is a brush for wandering
around because usually you have to wait
for the Umpire the bowler's end to call
over that means the ball is dead you
cannot be out then so he should have
waited for the Umpire to call over at
the end of the over or if he wanted to
go down the pitch and tap down the pitch
which happens often or talk to his mate
the captain it looks should look behind
it carries and sort of is it okay Carrie
shoot would have nodded and off he went
that's the only way you do it it didn't
do any of those so he was a bit Daft and
dozy Kerry did what you do instinctively
emotionally in the middle of a game but
I've been reflected on it Cummins him
the team should have said hang on hang
on a minute and if they couldn't do it
then they can do it now they can think
hang on we win the game brilliantly keep
played by both teams lots of wonderful
entertainment for everybody you've
spoiled it at the end you've tarnished
it you've tarnished your good name your
town is Cricket put your hand up say hey
in the Heat of the Moment We got it
wrong we'd like to say we foulsomely
apologized it won't happen again that
sort of thing check hands when you meet
Ben Stills move on everybody be much
happier because there's nothing wrong
with anybody me included we make
mistakes with human beings put your
under when you made a mistake and say
hey I got it wrong I'm sorry
okay do it again Melinda Farrell you've
heard that from the great Sir Jeffrey uh
one of the all-time great England
cricketers in ashes Legends who actually
in his column also told a fascinating
story which I'll just quickly paraphrase
where he was playing against the
Australians and he handled the ball and
the wiki keeper Wally Grau actually said
to him don't do that son rather than
appeal and get him out which was an
extraordinary act to sportsmanship
that's how it used to be Melinda you
cannot be happy
with what you witnessed there that's not
how Australia would feel happy winning
an ashes game is it
players feel quite okay about how that's
happened I actually agree with with
stuff some stuff that you've said
appears in there and with uh Sir Jeffrey
as well
look you there's there's so much water
Valkyrie that comes in into things like
this when it happens and I think because
passions are so inflamed people often
tend to see things through the prism of
which team it's happened to whether it's
their team or the opposition whether
they like that team and also whether
they win or lose I think it's a great
shame that this has overshadowed uh Ben
Stokes playing the most magnificent
Innings I've seen in place since the
last magnificent ridiculous Innings that
he played and maybe that wouldn't have
happened if it wasn't for this incident
because it fired him up to do something
incredible
I I think the spirit of cricket when
people start talking about that it can
be very nebulous it can mean different
things to different people you ask
people and it's very hard to Define
because it doesn't really Define
anything much in there apart
I thought about this I've heard people
say this I think you it's undefinable
there's no if it was definable it would
be written in the laws right the spirit
of cricket though comes when everybody
basically feels in their bones there's
something unfair has happened I think
and I don't think you can possibly look
at bearsto who you see scraping his boot
inside the crease which is what batsman
do either with their boot or their bat
to denote it's the end of an over and
then to casually walk down the speech
was captured every Australian player
knew what he was doing they all knew he
wasn't trying to get an advantage so to
run him out in the way that they did to
stump him as they tried to describe it I
don't think it's a stumping but whatever
you want to call it but for Pat Cummings
he's Mr Nice Guy uh after we had the
whole incident of course around
sandpaper gate where all hell broke
loose in Australia and many Australians
were as outraged as we were by sandpaper
gay I'm just surprised that Pat Cummings
who seems a pretty decent guy didn't do
the right thing and actually make the
world feel good about Australia and
sportsmanship
well I I think that's that's up to Pat
Cummins as far as where he thinks that
sort of dismissal Falls I do know that a
lot of people who have been contacting
me say that you see this a lot in it
it's instinctive from The Keeper so I
don't think anyone has an issue with it
actually being out and as so Jeffrey
said it was a mistake by besto so he's
made a mistake Kerry hasn't done the
right the wrong thing and it's something
that that a lot of Keepers do do
instinctively they had noticed he was
wandering out of his crease ambesto had
done something similar uh a couple of
them the person I blame the person I
blame is the captain because I've seen
Ms dhoni the former Indian captain in a
similar situation actually reversed the
decision withdraw the appeal this has
been done before and those captains by
the way when they do that kind of thing
they get revered forever in cricket
folklore for being Sportsman and that's
why again I'm surprised I want to bring
in Lord Marlin well Marlon I saw you on
day one of the laws test we were
enabling boxes enjoying the the uh the
match and then you were there yesterday
I think it was a very different
atmosphere what did you make of what
happened there and also what did you
make of what happened I was there I'm
sorry yeah I was there for three days
not yesterday but right okay so you were
there the first three days so but I
presume you watched what was going on
yesterday
um oh yeah what did you make of what
happened on the pitch and also what did
you make of what happened in the laws
Pavilion the scenes of which I I gotta
say I found the spectacle of MCC members
chanting cheat cheat was pretty
disgusting actually and I'm glad
action's been taken against him but it
showed the measure of the anger in the
ground uh what did you make of what
happened and the Fallout
well I totally agree with you which
often I do peers uh it was very
unsporting I think you're completely
right that the captain should have on
field made the decision look you know uh
well done Kerry but we're not going to
uh call you out go back to your crease
which would have been the sportsman-like
thing to do
of course in defensive Cummings it's a
very instant decision you've got to make
you don't have the opportunity of time
you have to make a decision at the
moment but I think the thing is defined
by Ben Stokes in a way and what he said
afterwards which and I think Ben Stokes
is one of the great sporting Heroes that
he said he wouldn't have done it himself
and that for me is good enough of course
uh the Rivalry you know it is just
another twist isn't it in the Australia
England or the ashes series is not an
attractive one they'll get booed every
time they walk out on the ground if
that's what they want that's fine I
totally agree with you about the
behavior in the long room it's very
unseemly but it you know Cricket has
moved on from this very polite life that
you have at the MCC to a contrast of
Edwardson where I was also
where there's this little rowdy crowd
really exciting atmosphere uh and so you
know it's where's that balance and of
course the long room for that point of
view is sacrificed but it could be
argued if you were out in the crowd
you'd have done that
Kevin McGuire instead of listening to
all this I mean are we as many
Australians claim you know Melinda
reference to what a battery there are
episodes in England's cricketing pass
which wouldn't shine up very well if you
put the spirit of qriket test to it
um I was at a game at the oval in 2008
when one of the New Zealand players ran
into our bowler a complete accident he
fell over and was run out and we we
didn't withdraw the appeal I thought
that was completely wrong so I think I'd
be consistent I don't like any of that
stuff what do you make of it yeah I'm
thinking Ollie Pope and New Zealand in
the slips uh is an lbw appeal the uh
kiwi batsman wanders out takes the uh
stumps off and bastos all you know high
fives and uh and great fun I think we're
in danger in England now what in England
the difference there is though yeah
nobody thought the play was dead now
play was still out well I think the
batsman did I don't think they thought
it was going to be an appeal it was what
he was waiting for for the Umpire and
the uh the play would be still act but I
think we're we're in danger of sounding
bad losers and uh whining whinging Palms
look it was in the rules this is the
ashes you know fiercest sporting contest
are you an Aussie Skipper going to give
that away Ben Stiller I would say if
you're I would say if your country has
been through sandpaper gate yeah with a
captain and Vice Captain both had to
resign their jobs in tears on television
this was a brilliant opportunity for
pack companies who by all accounts is a
good guy a great opportunity for him to
reset the profile of the Australian
cricket team on the global stage by
doing something that he may not
obviously interview wanted to but felt
actually was the right thing but it's
not Sun Peabody Sun people get was clear
we'll never cheated clear clear cheating
this is not cheating it was within the
rules the umpires upheld it what
happened to the umpire's decision as
final the umpires gave a man now I agree
with Lord Marlin though the behavior of
the uh who rear Henry's the uh Posh
Hooligans in the Pavilion look they've
got privileged access to the players
yeah it doesn't mean you have to you
know smother them with kisses uh I
didn't like that at all I thought that
was behave like that at all and also
chanting cheat cheat when they haven't
actually cheated I thought that was
completely wrong uh so Jeffrey let me
come back to you for the final word I
always like to do that uh the next test
match starts in a few days aheadingly
your neck of the woods your great ground
where you broke so many records this I
would imagine is going to fire up the
England team like nothing else could
possibly do it will also fire up that
Yorkshire crowd like nothing else could
possibly
for them let me tell you
they'll be ready for him no doubt at all
what do you have to remember
I don't like Kevin's point because if
everybody played to the rules absolute
letter of the rules what would happen
now is England and its players will be
looking to get their own back
so then we tip for that all the time
looking for gamesmanships underhand
things and the quickly as we know it
would disintegrate because players would
be looking to score a point get their
own back is that what we want to Cricket
no we want the tricky this and teams
just looking to get their own back
gamesmanship underhand things dirty
things you know I don't want that at
Cricket this the cricket played by these
two teams are fairly equal we've been
Daft enough to build stupid things at
the moments when we're winning the match
and we should have been doing it not too
nil down we're equal to them we could
easily beat them but we're doing death
thieves but that's not the point it's
not about the winning losing it it's
about the standards of the game and when
you're talking about the members of MCC
they're not all hooray henries with lots
of money and gone to private schools it
was an emotional moment I agree it was
unsavory and they deserve essential but
I don't think the diesel does have to
lose their membership at all it's an
emotional moment it certainly wasn't as
bad as what the Australian Captain
didn't do and I agree with you peers he
had a moment there an opportunity to
square things with the world because
what they did in Cape Town was pure and
simply cheating and that's why they got
chanting in the long run not just for
that incident it's for what they did in
Cape Town was that wasn't against the
spirit of the game that's pure and
simple cheating
so Jeffrey as always magnificent to
watch you budding uh thank you very much
today for joining me and Melinda thank
you be under bound England we're going
to win the ashes
I think we are going to win the ashes
3-2 I think the So Far Eastern Victory
and Melinda I want to thank you
especially because uh we couldn't get
any current or ex-australian player or
any other Australian media figure to
come on and you bravely came over the
parapet to defend your country
everyone's talking about cricket and the
ashes at a time when everyone says
Cricket's dying let's let's uh just
essentially certainly isn't dying now uh
great to see you lamanna great to see
you Kevin thank you very much indeed
well it says the next two British piers
are under five are attending a Russia
day party organized by the kremlin's man
in London I lost one of those Piers what
he was doing next
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Russia's ambassador to London Andre
Kellen is banned from the Palace of
Westminster over his country's illegal
war in Ukraine but that didn't stop two
British Lords attending his Russia day
party last month according to his only
times Kellin defended The Invasion and
condemned the British government while
guest quaffed valkyrus snacked on
bellinis one of the pairs Lord bath
represents the governing Conservative
Party in the House of Lords and he joins
me live from Westminster law balf what
were you doing at a party celebrating
Russia when the host of the party isn't
even allowed to be in our Parliament
well it was Russia's national day all
governments have national days in London
I was invited to the party I've been in
Russia only in Ukraine several times I
think we have to stop this war and we're
not going to stop it by shouting at each
other
well we're not going to stop it by by
partying with the Russians when they're
waging an illegal War are we
I think part is not exactly the most
accurate word for diplomatic reception
well there was a party um it was a party
yeah yeah it was celebrating the
creation of a Russian independent of the
Soviet Union
yeah
let's not squabble too much but it was a
reception everybody was totally well
behaved half the Commonwealth was there
which is something the Brits might like
to note
but my basic reason for being there is I
want to get this war stopped
and the first way of stopping it we've
got to get the Russians to say what they
actually want in Ukraine
still could running around the place
smashing it up we need to know what they
want so that we've got a basis
negotiation well the truth is they are
running around smashing it up and they
clearly want to take Ukraine uh Putin I
would say clearly wants to restore as
much of a Soviet Union as he can but
either way uh Kellen the Ambassador gave
a speech where he tried to justify the
invasion of Ukraine and condemned
Britain's confrontational foreign policy
did you at that stage interject and tell
him that actually the invasion was
illegal and the Britain's foreign policy
is not confrontational
I've already told him that the invasion
was certainly unwise and incidentally
illegal but uh no you don't interject in
situations like this
but I did make it quite clear that I
think the Russians need to work out a
way of stopping the fighting and the
first bit of that is to be quite clear
as to what they want and he's no good
wanting to conquer Ukraine because all
they would do is they would end up with
a civil war that would go on and on and
on so we need a much clearer focus and
shouting from the sidelines and arming
them I understand the latest idea is to
give them cluster bombs I don't think
that's very smart well the alternative
is that Ukraine's incidentally I'm not I
don't represent the conservative party
no no I sit as a conservative member
sure no I understand but you're there
because you're there as a conservative
member of the House of Lords many people
were outraged at you either hobnobbing
with the Russian Ambassador given the
current situation it's not an unwise
invasion it's an illegal barbaric
Invasion where many tens of thousands of
ukrainians have been slaughtered and the
truth is if we don't arm them in the way
that we've been arming them many many
more will be slaughtered I mean that's
pretty self-evident isn't it
well if we want to run a proxy war in
the middle of Europe where two different
sides kill each other mercilessly go
ahead I'd rather gate for peace well we
don't love peace but stop we'd all love
peaceful would you would you for example
ukrainians can go back home but we'd all
love that
with respect everybody would love peace
everyone in Ukraine would love to go
back to how things were Unfortunately
they are having a war waged on them by
Vladimir Putin and his murderous Army
now let me ask you this would you have
gone to a party for example if it was
hosted by a Nazi Ambassador at the start
of World War II
we don't have a Nazi Ambassador well
would you have gone to the German
ambassador's residence for a nice party
as the Nazis were embarking on their uh
global domination plan
if I'd have been interested in Germany
like
um Chamberlain and Rob Butler foreign
office I would probably have gone to the
German Embassy
up to Czechoslovakia but not afterwards
all right so you have party limits
yes
it's good to know Lord Bell thanks for
joining me uh Kevin good
I don't think he should be attending no
parties the Russian Ambassador I don't
think he should be there saying this
invasion was unwise no and I think he's
got this rather quaint I did that so
many of them have who sort of do these
kind of things with the Russians of we
all want peace well of course we do but
the ukrainians haven't started this war
yeah look Richard balf Lord balth was a
useful idiot as a propaganda coup for
the Kremlin they can say they have
members of the House of Lords ruling new
care conservative government from that
party at their reception yeah and we we
saw one of the latest atrocities a dozen
people including three children killed
in a pizza restaurant and he's going to
somewhere where they're serving food and
drink yeah the hobnob with the
Ambassador I think he's got a misguided
view of his own self-importance and he
thinks he's going to have any real role
with the Russians but you know to say it
to say it is unwise that Invasion I'm
sorry that sounds a little bit to me
like an apologetic way it does look it
was
evoked aggression against economy that
is cost probably now it lies more than a
hundred thousand on the on the two sides
many more people injured Ukraine trashed
it's not a proxy war I'm a peace Nick
yeah you probably won't get anyone more
opposed to Wars than than me but I can
see wedding Ukraine is invaded in this
way you can do nothing but send weapons
and support it and hope Putin or
somebody at some point will withdraw
Kevin good to talk to you and good to
stay on thank you very much everyone's
talking about Barbie subject to the most
hotly anticipated movie of the year but
assumed a secret man hater is that what
this movie is all about we'll debate
that next with three women
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
this is talk TV
foreign
[Music]
has long been criticized by feminists as
a symbol of unattainable princess-like
perfection the iconic metal doll is now
the inspiration for a Hollywood movie
one of the most anticipated of the
entire year capping Barbie's Evolution
from symbol of the patriarchy to
feminist icon
[Music]
Bobby has smart new styles for every
occasion for dates with Ken club
meetings tennis
meet me at the mall what you gonna say
next listen do you have a crush on
anyone
anybody know how big the brain is
Sophia it is Mia
medium what's going on why are these men
looking at me yeah they're also staring
at me
[Music]
so Fantastic Plastic feminist icon all
sexist claptrap with the movie's
outrageously dismissive tagline she is
everything he is just Ken as Barbie
actually done a full 180. is she now
anti not just Ken but men well I'm
joined by talk TV uh contributor Esther
cracker and also by George V presenter
Rosanna loved one and also drum roll
back from the world's longest holiday
bye Grace Blakely our socialist
commentator I love calling you that have
you come record that welcome back
we've almost missed you I have missed
you very much as well obviously and
you're wearing your Barbie outfit I have
apparently been talking
you did this on purpose I mean yes
you did this to seduce that is a massive
compliment honestly if I look anything
like Margot Robbie I will take that so
look let's start with with you then on
this giving you come dressed as Barbie
so there are a number of Barbie
characters in the movie right one plays
President Barbie one plays Dr Barbie one
plays a Barbie with a Nobel Prize in
physics one is a mermaid Barbie however
all the male characters in Barbie world
are simply called Ken so it's pretty
clear where this movie is going this is
an assault on not just Ken but all men I
mean I think men in general will have to
be a bit kind of snowflakey suggest
they're being assaulted by a Barbie
movie but I kind of think that's besides
the point I mean I think you know the
the question that we have around this
one whether or not Bobby is a feminist
icon actually well I think it matters
less than the fact that the Barbie
franchise has commercialized the
feminist critique so now you can be like
oh you can feel like a good feminist
because you buy a doll for 25.99 or you
can feel like a hashtag girl boss
because Barbie has a Nobel Prize or
Barbie's an entrepreneur whereas
actually feminism is rooted in the
struggles of ordinary women it's about
the fact that you know women often get
paid less it's about the fact that women
are on the front line of some of the
hardest sectors to work in in care what
in um in our Healthcare System and
social care it's about the fact they do
so much unpaid
laborers
have you ever met a female Brickler I
don't know no you haven't but I love the
assumption that being a bricklayer is
harder than like caring for the terminal
ill and dying have you ever been a
Bricker in the winter but like have you
ever been somewhere yes I actually have
yeah
very very challenging job isn't it and
like not as hard as being a bricklayer
in what sense
physically challenging emotionally
challenging I mean they're a care
workers who are running up and down
between houses getting paid less than
minimum wage I get that but you don't
you don't make a fortune as a bricklayer
either and you're out in in the element
I just don't understand
each other it's a bizarre culture let me
try and get one single word in here um
so Rosanna look Barbie's jobs include
being an astronaut a surgeon Olympic
Athlete downhill skier aerobics
instructor TV news reporter vet Rockstar
doctor army officer Air Force pilot
Summit Diplomat rap musician
presidential candidate baseball player
scuba diver lifeguard firefighter
engineered dentists and many more I mean
she's not a bad feminist icon she's done
everything she's had over 200 careers
apparently since she was first conceived
but you know is she a feminist icon look
when you said unattainable princess
perfect like Perfection this is what you
were thinking of these three women here
I think all three of us Perfectly
Imperfect can we settle on that
we probably all played with Barbies
going off I'm going to guess that given
Barbie's enormous reach now given how
many different Barbie dolls are there
you can almost have a Barbie doll for
any type whatever is she legitimately a
feminist icon no I don't think she is
but there are other toys available if
you don't like her
to be a feminist icon why can't girls
just play with pretty dolls
anything to do with feminism I don't
think that feminism should be co-opted
by Massive multinational corporations
well that's fine but I don't think
but Grace what about if it's shaping the
way young girls are growing up that's
well I mean I think this is the problem
people have with feminism this is why we
end up having all these debates about
like oh you know
feminism doesn't account for the
struggles of ordinary people and it's
just like very rich and wealthy women at
the top of companies saying I want more
money it's because feminism which is
actually a critique of capitalism in
part has been taken over by big monster
corporations to basically say look we
have three women on our board so the
gender struggle is over and it's just
this is a symptom of a wider problem all
right you mentioned gender the bank of
England says anyone can get pregnant of
any gender identity
uh they've offered to help pay uh help
staff to pay for gender reassignment
treatment including now this has all
been going on in your absence
ad nauseam some might think this whole
gender debate but this concept that
anyone of any gender identity can become
pregnant is obviously ludicrous I mean
I'm going to start before even opening
up into this discussion talking about
yes I've been away for nine months and
I've come back and watched how our
entire political debate has become
dominated by this tiny tiny Fringe issue
we have this massive moral panic over an
issue that affects so few people the
climate is literally like the Earth is
a massive cost of living prices going on
I was honestly just shocked that this is
what we're doing you can care about the
climate and you can also care about the
full frontal attack on the Integrity of
women's sport because of transgender
athletes you can care about men rapists
being put into female prisons like cos
Nicola sturgeon her job by the way you
can care about all those issues too and
yet I would have thought you would have
come back and gone you know what I've
seen the light Biz you're right about
this and yeah this is what we're talking
about I think there is a reason why we
are talking about this issue rather than
the bank of England just raised interest
rates that's going to mean that millions
of families are not going to be able to
repay their debt repay their loans
they're going to be pushed into poverty
and here we are talking about some you
know I think you've just hit the nail on
the head because shouldn't the bank of
England be more concerned with bringing
down inflation rates than you know
offering the ability
I'm sure this was just some sort of
random thing
or economics if you look at the Crux of
the issue this was actually probably a
freedom of information request Stonewall
uh the bank of England applied to
Stonewall to say we want to be in your
top 100 list of diversity and inclusion
sort of index thing this was last year
they made this application the
information has only been revealed now
and I would say that that is the
Telegraph and the other papers
capitalizing on the argument that the
bank of England says has lacks monetary
policy and they're trying to make the
argument that they've been too focused
on diversity playing up to cold but
let's be clear
well you can have a hundred and twenty
thousand genders as many as you like
only women can and get pregnant but like
I mean that's just a biological fact
only women get pregnant people you can
have as many gender debates as you want
you can feel like a mouse or like it but
you can't actually pretend anyone but
other than the biological female can
have a baby sure only people who are
born women can get pregnant people who
are born women can also become men
can also legitimately become mothers
biological men are biological men yeah I
mean if they could be more women they
can be a trans man that's something on
that why do we have to change it I made
this point to you like years ago and I
thought we kind of settled it you know
you have CIS women and trans women in
CIS men and trans men we don't have to
get all up in arms about all this stuff
it just doesn't matter that much I'm so
glad you do still get up in arms about
it I really miss this uh Esther I mean I
agree with you the bank of England get
on with fixing yeah the economics is the
Optics of this that's even more
frustrating because you don't want a
news story of the bank of England you
know paying for the employees gender
transitioning when they're clearly
bigger issues at hand here
um but I I think it's just this
obsession with companies that feel like
they have to you know talk about these
issues all the time I'm just happy for
business to function as a business I'd
like to know their stance on gender
identity or anything like me I actually
agree well that's in itself a shocking
moment do any of you have a view about
Johnny best and the way he was out at
Lords I saw this my dad showed me this
was the clip where did your dad say my
dad said that that it was slightly
unfair to have knocked him out and that
there should have been
um what did he say that it should have
been reviewed or something and the
ordinarily that that's what would have
happened because there was some
president your dad's right okay no idea
no view no view yeah
joins me live until Iran immigration
while the late Queen uncanceled him
strawberry twist
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
coming up on the talk we'll see soon at
Wades into the ashes round backing Ben
Stokes and criticizing Australia but the
prime minister's own back benches say he
needs to focus on migration right now
and cut numbers by two-thirds before the
next election plus banks have been
slammed for blacklisting customers with
anti-work opinions that's all coming up
at nine foreign
[Music]
stand-up comedian he's now turn the
spotlight onto free speech and the
vicious regime and his family's native
Iran Ahmed great to have you back on the
program let me start before we get to
Iran which is a passion thing that you
want to talk about and I get that
this Rwanda
story ongoing about how we're going to
deal with the small boats with refugees
Asylum Seekers and perhaps people trying
it on as well what's your take on it
well you know I'm very as a proud
Iranian I'm very happy to tell you that
on on the UN building there's a Persian
poet called Sardi who has his poem on
the building and the translation says if
you do not feel human pain the name
human you cannot retain and I think
that's really powerful because where I
live in Suffolk now I've got to know
some Iranian Asylum Seekers who
literally run away they've been here
since January they've run away from the
regime and they're very frustrated
because they can't work they love Iran
they don't want to be in Britain but now
they're here they want to contribute one
of them is a tennis player and we did
this turkey Syria benefit gig and they
spoke they spoke so powerfully they were
saying why can't we make love and unity
the dictatorship why can't we to see the
world as one Globe is very very
important I think when we saw Fiona
Bruce on question time asking do you
agree with the Rwanda it was amazing it
was amazing not a single hand went up
and it was insanely a conservative yeah
I thought that was a really wonderful
moment and it really gave me hope that
British people are good and we
understand and that when people run away
they're running away from awful regimes
that we're going to talk about where if
they stay there they'd be killed they're
not all running from awful regime no not
all I mean we had the issue without a
lot of Albanian young Albanian economic
migrants coming and so on where do we
draw the line what what is the right way
to handle this well I don't know but all
I can tell you is that knowing these
Iranian uh Asylum Seekers and their
Asylum seekers in the sense that they
can't work until they have their uh
residential papers we have to speed
things up because they've been here for
five six months they're desperate to
come to processing systems it's awfully
broken yeah exactly and that's causing a
lot of the irritations I think
um is a great story The the queen was
upset with the BBC for editing out your
migrant joke about Rwanda it was ITV I
think there was a little segment where
uh uh the night before we had some
practice nights and I did this joke
about please uh for God's sake don't
send me to Rwanda and there's ITV said I
think we'll we'll drop that for the
queen it was ITV it was for the the
there was the one course show was a
pageant the Jubilee pageant and she was
a bit upset because she heard that
because what happened to the Miranda
joke and because it got cut and she was
a bit annoyed but then again I
understand because you can't show the
royal family commenting on governmental
policies so it makes it interesting that
she would have preferred it in they've
got a great sense of humor you've got to
they they do love a laugh and and she
and I did do a joke about how thanks for
choosing us over the state opening a
parliament it was the big elephant in
the room she did that thing with the
hand like you know you're very cheeky
but I like your kind of things that was
fun let's turn to Iran uh and the women
of Iran in particular this has been a
big running story now for a while
do we care enough in the west about
what's going on here is there enough of
a light being shot well on the one sense
there is a women-led revolution going on
and we're all surprised that the Western
press are not picking up on it but there
is this campaign which I'm very proud to
stand with which is called our story as
one campaign that reminds everyone a lot
of Iranians don't know about this 40
years ago 10 women 10 Baha'i women and
of course they're part of a faith which
was outlawed in Iran they were asked to
recount their beliefs or face the death
and they they didn't and it was an
amazing moment of standing up for for
freedom of expression freedom of thought
and freedom of belief and all ten were
hanged and one of them was a 17 year old
girl called Mona Mahmoud who then became
very well known not just for being
someone who was very powerfully stood
against the regime but she also became a
poster person for child execution six
years later there was that the United
Nations put these things where they to
stop child executions because she was 17
years old and unfortunately the only
country that still carries out child
executions is the Islamic Republic of
Iran you because of your outspokenness
on this issue it's been very courageous
but you've had a huge amount of attacks
on social media from Iranian Bots and so
on we saw what happened to Salma Rusty
of course
um which is a vicious attack on his free
speech Yes do you worry about this I
worry a bit for my mental health because
what I'm doing is I'm trying to give my
social media over to the voiceless
because you know what they do first
before they start killing people they
cut the internet so through VPN they put
out a couple of videos and those of us
go through it and they're really
horrific and I can only put out a few
things which I think are palatable for
an English-speaking audience uh but at
the same time I think it's very
important to get stories out loud for
the 10 women of Shiraz what we did we
did this little video about an English
girl playing the last moments for life
and the question was that just because
it's not happening here it doesn't mean
it's not happening so I think that even
though I'm being attacked I am more
worried about my own mental health
seeing all these horrific videos but at
the same time social media is our weapon
and you've got to keep putting it out
what's your key message to people
watching this about what's happening in
Iran it's it's basically get involved
have a look what's going on the the our
story as one campaign is also a creative
one have a look at how we can support
the women of Iran and also we have to
say with someone Russia was being you
you know attacked and killed and there
were all these videos of people you know
the the Islamic Republic of Iran he's
still alive obviously yeah he's still
alive yeah but still tried to kill him
they tried to kill him but the Islamic
Republic are putting out all these
videos asking jihadists to kill people
blow up embassies blow up libraries and
why we're asking the big question why is
it why is it that Isis there was a
concerted effort to eradicate them but
the Islamic Republic of Iran are Vice
chairman of this of the secret of the
general assembly great to see you thanks
for coming in I appreciate it thank you
that's it from me what you're up to keep
it uncensive good night
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]